thanks so much for being on the program
so you are there at the coronation
yesterday any particular highlights uh I
was it was just uh everything was so
fabulous a huge advert for Global
Britain you know a spectacle watched by
millions of people across across the
globe I really loved the procession
because you know you saw everything
there you know religious leaders you
know leaders of their countries in their
traditional dress and then you know you
saw a princess Charlotte with Prince
Louis holding hands I just thought that
was a huge moment of you know
International solidarity yeah that was
lovely that moment when they were
holding hands I thought as well and
you've got a busy day today as well
planned busy day today so um yes later
on I'll be going with the prime minister
to the luncheon number 10 we'll be
hosting people you know who've been made
massive contributions to their uh to
their local communities and there'll be
some ukrainians there as well so it's
going to be a really fabulous event and
then really lucky to be invited tonight
to the coronation continent
which will show the best of our British
culture I mean it's been amazing weekend
of spectacle but frankly it has been a
difficult few years for the royal family
some might be asking if they're still
relevant I think they make a massive
contribution to society you know just
yesterday you know seeing 200
representatives from across the globe
there because of the coronation
um I think that shows their their power
and their pull and they do so much you
know for communities uh and the good
works that they do you know I work uh
very closely with the princess trust you
know what they're doing for young people
so I do think they have a significant
role in society not everyone agrees of
course there were a number of arrests uh
yesterday
do you think the Met police went too far
uh you know the police are operationally
independent uh from government but what
they had to do was to police you know an
International Event uh on the world
stage and I think they took that into
account in their policing and what they
have to do is balance the right of
people's uh the right to protest which
is important in a democracy at the same
time as the right of all those other
people to enjoy what was a fabulous day
and and I I don't know the the instances
the particular instances but I think
overall they managed to get that balance
right you say that overall you believe
they managed to get the balance rights
um but there are reports of for example
three volunteers working for Westminster
counties Night Safety team arrested for
handing out rape alarms another person
arrested for possessing a megaphone
because it might scare the horses I mean
for some people they might be saying
that hang on
um yes the people have a right to enjoy
um the coronation and the processions
but also people have a right at the
correlation to also make their views
heard of their Auntie Monica it's really
difficult to take snapshots of
particular cases because we don't know
all the facts around that we don't know
whether events for example were
coordinated so I think it's that's very
very very difficult analysis to make but
I think what we've seen in this country
is a rise in protests and the way people
are protesting that is interfering with
the rights of people to go around their
daily life you know it's stopping
ambulances stopping people get to school
stopping people going on motorways and
getting to work and I think we need to
redress that and that's what we've done
in Parliament to bring in new laws to
ensure that the balance is redressed and
we get that balance right I want to talk
about that in a minute um but that's not
what we saw was it at the correlation
protest and that's quite important to
say the Met police said that they
understand the concern but they police
proportionately and in the context of
the event I just wonder that phrase in
the context of the event does that mean
there are different thresholds for
policing a protests around coronation
well we should say I know the police
said that they understand the public
concerns but there were a large number
of protests that took place yesterday
with the police knowledge that were able
to go ahead I think it is really
important that they take into account
the context of of the event because this
was an event that would have raised
questions about National Security this
was an event on the world stage and I
think it is really important for the
police to put that their policing into
that context and you mentioned the extra
powers that you've given to the police
to police protests including pounds to
stop and search without suspicion
including saying that a policeman may
stop any person or vehicle that they see
think fit to whether or not they have
any grounds for suspecting the person's
carrying a prohibited object
trust the police to use these new Pals
fairly uh well if they don't use them
fairly then there are consequences so
yes I mean I think policing is very
difficult the police are operationally
independent they have difficult
challenges but do you trust them to use
these new palettes yes I do trust them
to use those new powers I've had a
number of meetings with the police over
the course of the last few weeks
obviously uh in relation to the
coronation to check everything they felt
was on track and I have huge confidence
in the police I mean some of these
protesters are we're talking generally
now about the reason why we've brought
in this legislation I mean over the last
year the police have spent 14 million
pounds dealing with just stop oil
protests I think it's absolutely right
that they have the powers that they need
in order to ensure that people can go to
go on their day-to-day lives at the same
time as respecting people's right to
protest I guess I'm asking a question
specifically about the police because
you know we've just seen a very
important review saying that their map
police is institutionally racist and
misogynistic more than 90 officers found
guilty of crimes themselves last year
from violence to sexual offenses public
confidence understandably at a real low
is this the time to be giving the police
more powers
uh well wait you asked me a question
about the operational ability of course
the police have had a difficult time and
the reviews that you have mentioned and
the unfortunate instance uh you know
have taken place and there have been
there have been reviews to ensure that
there's more police vetting which is
absolutely right
um obviously police should be respecting
um the the people that they deal with
Witnesses victims and women
um and I think those steps are now being
taken okay
I want to move on to the local elections
if I may and how would you describe your
performance
well first of all I would like to say
you know lots of counselors have lost
their seat from from a variety of
parties and they've worked really hard
in their local communities and of course
that is a real shame party in particular
though wouldn't you say well you're
right to say that we we have been in
government now for 13 years we've been
if we could look at the context for the
whole uh local election uh we've been in
power for a long time we've just had a
pandemic which has disrupted many
people's lives and has had consequences
for the economy as has the war in
Ukraine which is going on and we
understand the concerns of the British
people you know what we're focusing on
now is ensuring that we cut inflation
and we're having some success there you
know cut the debt uh grow the economy
and make sure that we protect the NHS
you know it's it's sometimes I feel like
the last couple of days listening to you
conservative politicians reflecting the
results
do you really get what's happened
totally totally it's really important
that we listen to people I know people
are frustrated
this isn't just oh look we've had 13
years of course we're going to dip a few
seeds like hundreds and hundreds of
seats were lost by the conservatives
labor now yes the largest party in local
government I mean you're losing all over
the place Medway Windsor basically
anyone who's up against you greens even
we're taking seats do you get what we've
had totally and we've had a really on
top of the things I mentioned I totally
recognize we've had a really difficult
few years I do think that the Prime
Minister who's now been in office for
six months is getting the country back
on track and is delivering and I think
we're starting to gain the trust of the
British public but we have we have we
have absolutely what's your evidence for
that that you're gaining the trust of
the British public what has rejected you
at the local elections um well in my own
seat obviously I've spent a large number
of hours knocking on doors and speaking
to people across my constituency and
I've seen a little bit of a shift in the
last even from the beginning of the
campaign to the end of the campaign you
know they were angry and frustrated and
the cost of living is difficult but I
think what they are seeing and I hope
what they're seeing is that the prime
minister is starting to deliver in a
quiet way for the British people and
just just to come on to the other
parties you know labor didn't have it
did well
um I I accept that but if he wants to
get a majority at the next election it
needed to do better so you know the
statistics show that if to win at a
general election in the previous local
election you need to be 13 14 points up
and they're around eight points up so
they do need to do better look we can
have a debate over whether or not these
results show that labels and calls for a
minority or majority government but what
the results show is that you guys are on
course being turfed out
so we've got somewhere to go we need to
continue working hard I totally
understand that we need to do better and
I think we are going to deliver that I'm
going to say
um and and I totally recognize that uh
we could have done much better and the
results were not good but you know in my
own constituency we were facing
um we we held the council by uh onesie
previously and we still hold the council
so you know there are areas in the
country where the results were okay so
how are you going to change them if
you're listening to what the voters are
saying I I read in the papers that you
apparently the government Minister who
topped the league table for doing the
most campaigning out and about so you're
the one talking to voters you're
listening to them if you're hearing
their message how does your government
need to change
we need to deliver on what matters to
people and I think what matters most to
them is their day-to-day spending and
the cost of living and our our key focus
is getting inflation down so no change
then things and ears because that's what
you just said before right uh well we
need to deliver people need to see that
we're a government that says what it's
going to do and then it delivers it so
that's what we've said we're going to do
and we've started on that Journey but we
need to deliver it
um and then I think once we have
delivered it and people have seen
progress then we earn their trust back
and we can start talking to them and
delivering on other things as well some
of your colleagues I think that the
change needs to be a bit more rapid
frankly
um I've spoken to some concerto MPS who
say that Russia student act as a problem
John Redwood has been busy tweeting this
morning not where she's Uno's biggest
fan it must be said but look this is
just one of his tweets that we can have
a look at last Thursday many
conservative voters went on strike they
don't want to vote for higher taxes as
anti-enterprise policies and a failure
to Take Back Control of our borders he
went on to say if taxes have to be this
High Why are public services not better
well I think well first
I worked with Rishi for a year in the
treasury and I think he's outstanding at
delivering his decent hard-working and I
think he is showing he's capable of
delivering and he scores well in the
polls so I think he's doing a good job
obviously there's still more we need to
do we are doing those things we are
doing those things well the best the
biggest tax cut we can make is a cut in
inflation that's that's not really what
John Webb was talking about there was
he's talking about the tax burner well
I'd like well the most important thing
is what do people feel like how do they
feel the economy is affecting them and a
cut in inflation is the biggest tax cut
they can get we are not actually a tax
cut is it you can't say you're
delivering what he wants because he's
asking for tax cards well you know what
I think is important is that people feel
the effect in their pocket so you know
the first step of that is to cut
inflation we are taking back control of
our borders you know you will know we're
taking on legislation you'll know we've
done a deal with Albania you'll know
we're working with French you know we
are making sure that we stop the boats
and we take control of our immigration
and the ensure that people come here
come here legally and through safe
routes okay I just want to talk a little
bit with your media hats on if I may as
well and I spoke to you kirst armor last
weekend who said that there are still
outstanding issues when it comes to
regulation of the media and press is he
right
uh well I think that I'm very proud of
our media um I think it's a we are a
democracy and it's really important that
we have uh Free Speech you'll know I'm
also in charge of the BBC and I think
the BBC is a huge asset to this country
uh we will be repealing section 40 and
to ensure that the media continues to
have that ability to hold politicians
and others to account I mean there has
been a lot of scrutiny hasn't there of
the BBC recently with the resignation of
Richard Sharp the chairman is it time as
kirst armor is saying to take all
political interference out of that role
no
um and I think it's interesting he says
that because when labor is in power they
made political appointments yeah but he
wants to do a different thing doesn't he
he's not he's saying that look let's
just change the whole thing going
forward the BBC a charter sets out how
the BBC chairman is appointed and we
will be following the BBC Charter but
what's really important to state is that
in selecting the next chair of the BBC
we will be looking for the best
candidate and that will be our Focus who
is the going to be the best chair of the
BBC and if they happen to have political
allegiances or they've supported a party
in the past whether that is the
conservative party or the labor party or
indeed any other party I don't think
that should disqualify them if they are
the best candidate for the job that's
the problem isn't it I guess people are
questioning whether or not the best
candidate for the job has always been
the criteria no the the the the criteria
on which I will be appointing and I'm
sure the Prime Minister will be
appointing the next chair the BBC is the
best candidate for the job and I do not
so there might be a labor supporter I
strongly believe uh that we should not
disqualify people from public office who
put themselves forward who are capable
of doing a job because they happen to
have in the past support to the
political so you'll be looking at Labor
candidates and conservations I've been
looking for the best candidate for the
job okay Eurovision next weekend yes
what's your prediction bye
I don't make predictions uh I'm really
looking forward I won't hold you I'm
really looking forward to going
um
really and it's not just actually about
your revision and the song contest uh
the city of Liverpool has done a
phenomenal job of uh supporting and
promoting Ukrainian culture I've spoken
to the Ukrainian culture Minister a
number of times I'm really looking
forward to hosting him as well and I
think it's just going to be a huge
celebration recognizing the strategy
that's going on in Ukraine at the moment
thank you very much thank you